A small multiple, sometimes known as a trellis or
a lattice plot is a series of charts laid out in a grid.
They often represent common data faceted by different categories.
In this case we have engineering,
operations, accounting, HR, IT, and manufacturing.
On the X axis we have different months of the year.
And on the Y axis we have different salary expenses for each department.
I really love small multiple plots because you can embed any type of chart and
they generalize to any type of comparison.
Here we've embedded line plots to show how
salary expenses vary over months of the year for each department.
But we could have just as easily embedded different histograms, maps, or
even pie charts.
The small multiple was popularized in coin by Edward Tufte,
a leader in the field of data visualization.
We'll learn more about him later in the lesson.
And we'll hear about him throughout the course.
Box plots are another technique to visualize multiple distributions in
one graphic.
Just like a small multiple, a series of box plots allow us to
visualize different distributions all in one graphic.
The box plot was invented by John Tukey and
comes from the field of exploratory data analysis.
While small multiple and box plots are often used for
exploratory data analysis to learn how your data's distributed.
They can also be used to convey certain points and
relationships between your data and your variables.
For example, in the box plot here, we have a series of experiments, one,
two, three, four, and five, measuring the speed of light.
And for each experiment we take a series of measurements that are visualized as
a single box plot.
Here we can see the quartile ranges, and the mean.
And we can plot these side by side to see what we likely believe the speed of
light to be after a series of experiments.
We can see here, the true speed of light is actually plotted in the red line,
and is quite a bit lower than all the experiments shown here.
Just one last point on the difference between EDA and data visualization,
typically in EDA you're trying to discover some information about your data for
yourself, whereas with a data visualization you're trying to
communicate some information about your data to others.
Depending upon your intention, you can use both box plots and small multiples to
either learn more about your data or try to convey something to others